The prophet Muhammad sallallah.aihi
wasallam told us that whoever builds a
mosque for Allah, Allah will build for
him a sim at a house in Jenna. And we
know the great reward that will not only
be gained but rather will fill your
grave after your death. Whenever someone
prays there, whenever someone gives
shahada in the masid, whenever someone
learns something in the masid, yes, that
will be something that you'll have on
your scale.
[Music]
How are you guys doing? Ponzi scheme
expert Patrick Bet David has come on his
show again speaking about matters that
are way above his pay grade with another
person who's not a specialist on these
matters. speaking about Islam and
Muslims. Again, an issue he's been
hyperfixated with and obsessed with for
a very long time now. And you can sense
his resentment and embitterment as a
disgruntled man that he is with Islam's
growth and success throughout the years
and presently. Let's take a look at this
first part of the clip and come back and
respond in kind. How is this a real
religion?
You know, it's just we just talked about
all these beautiful things about Christ
and him coming and suffering and his
humility and his passion, all these
things. It's a beautiful story. It's
very compelling. And then you see
Muhammad as a warrior and then he's, you
know, there's even the story he once
tried to commit suicide and he marries
this, you know, he's a polygamist and
marries this girl. I'm just thinking how
I don't understand how you would think
that this is the true religion. But
>> all right, so let's deal with this first
set of contentions
or interrogations which I find in
themselves actually implicit admissions
of key differences between Islam and
Christianity.
So notice how he compares the prophet
Muhammad to Jesus. Okay, the prophet
Muhammad to Muslims is a prophet. Jesus
to Christians is a god. In fact, in all
three major churches, Catholicism,
Protestantism, and Orthodox
Christianity, Jesus is God. Jesus is
God. Therefore, should not be compared
with the prophet. However, because he in
his mind deep down believes actually
that Jesus is a mere mortal, that he's a
man and that he's a prophet, he found it
more appropriate to compare Muhammad
with Jesus, which in a sense he's right
to do that. In a sense, he's right to do
that. from our perspective.
So the fact that he's had to compare his
God with a prophet, not his god with the
Islamic conception of God, which is
Allah, the creator of the heavens and
the earth, the most powerful, the most
gracious, the most merciful, the
beneficent, the forgiving. It shows that
he actually deep down he does believe
that Jesus was a man and nothing more
than that. Of course, that's what we as
Muslims believe.
We believe that Jesus was the Messiah,
that he was a prophet, and that he was
one of the most mighty prophets and
messengers that was ever sent to the
earth, that he was a man amongst men
with wonders and miracles and signs, as
the Bible says, that God did through
him. We accept this. We accept that
Jesus was all those things, but he was
not God or the son of God because it's
not conceivable or intelligible that
somebody with a date of birth could be
God. Then he talks about the the fact
that the prophet Muhammad had multiple
women as if that is a disqualifier from
prophethood. So if engaging in polygamy
is a disqualifier from prophethood,
then why does the Bible state that one
of the great men actually the son of God
in a sense that he was you know so wise
that God has bestowed him with wisdom
Solomon who was a prophet also in the
Bible. Why has Solomon got 700 wives and
300 concubines? If it was a disqualifier
from being a prophet, then Solomon
should have been disqualified.
But he wasn't indeed. The prophet only
had nine wives at one time compared to
Solomon's 700. That pales in comparison.
But you see, you cannot apply consistent
standards. That's the problem with you.
And then you speak about Jesus, you
know, compelling story and humble. Your
God humbled himself and died on the
cross. All of this stuff is incoherent,
by the way. All of this stuff is
absolutely inco
God, why have you forsaken me? I wonder
who he was talking to if not himself. If
he himself was the true God.
Then you move on to talk about the
prophet wanted to commit suicide. But
there is no authentic narration that
says that the prophet wanted to commit
suicide. There is nothing at all. In
fact the addition in Bkari as
mentions is added by which is a someone
who said that his level of sadness was
so high that he may have wanted to
commit suicide etc. But that's not from
the words of the prophet. He's not
narrating that himself. See, a little
bit of research goes a very long way.
But for the sake of argument, for the
sake of argument, I'll ask you a
question. Why is that a disqualifier
from prophethood?
Why is that a disqualifier from prophet?
Then he goes on to say he he made no he
had no miracles.
Now this is a be huge blunder, massive
blunder. What if I were to tell you that
in by one of the great scholars of Islam
that he states that the prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam had 1,200
miracles 1,200.
In fact, some of the miracles that are
associated with Jesus Christ, healing
people, etc. are the same miracles that
are associated with the prophet Muhammad
with more reliable chains of narration.
We have miracles where the prophet
sallallam water gushed through his hand
and an entire army for example was
quenched their thirst was quenched with
such water that came from his hand. We
have miracles of the prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam where he made
food multiply small food multiply into a
lot of food and this is once again
mentioned in the authentic authentic
tradition. Now once again I could sit
here and talk about so many miracles and
so many prophecies and there's in fact
many books that are written on this one
that you can access is called the
forbidden prophecies by Abu Zakariah
where he details so many of the
prophecies of the prophet Muhammad even
relating to our present day for example
the proliferation of interest rates for
example the preation of proliferation of
sexually transmitted diseases the like
of which didn't exist before so the
advent of STDs the proliferation
of written material. Also, the fact that
the barefooted Arabs will compete for
the highest buildings and so on and so
on and so forth. And this is relevant to
you as a Christian, whoever the your
name is. Sorry to say, I don't know what
your name is. I don't know it. Yeah. But
it's relevant to you because in
Deuteronomy chapter number 18 verse
number 21 it indicates that
a disqualifier of a prophet is that if
he speaks about the future and he gets
it wrong. So what we understand from
that is what we expect from a prophet is
to speak about the future and get it
right. But there's never been a prophet
in history that has spoken in such a way
with such frequency and accuracy about
future events that stretch all the way
to our times including the conquest of
the Muslims and where Islam would spread
by country
where it would go
except for the prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
And if you're interested in this, you
can go to my website muhammad hijab.com
and I have a PDF document which is free
of charge proofs for the evidences of
Islam. If you're a sincere person, you
actually want to know the answer to your
question. Why is it that people are
converting to Islam? Why is it that
people believe in Islam? Why is Islam a
compelling proposition to so many
people? Instead of thinking, oh, it's
because of the discipline aspect and
this and that. No, it's because of it's
because of the very simple proposition
that there's only one God worthy of
worship,
the evidences that come with Islam.
And then after that, you have the laws
which also reinforce a person's life. So
when you have all those things together,
you have a compelling case. one though
that you haven't looked into very well
and you sound like an ignorant person,
but let's see what else you say so I can
refute you and we can move on. I He just
seem to live a bad life. I'm saying not
a prophet.
Two billion people know how does that
happen?
How does that happen? You know, you go
to a company, you use a product that's
bad. Eventually, people figure out the
product doesn't work. Keeps breaking.
You buy a toy, keeps breaking, keeps
breaking, keep not going to buy this
anymore. I'm going to go buy this other
company.
What has attracted this product to grow
the weight that that it has?
>> It might be better than the product they
had before. That's the only thing that
>> What did they have before?
>> Uh animism, paganism.
>> So the tail end of that, we saw him say
it might be better than the product that
they had before, not realizing that the
so-called product that they had before
was Christianity. In fact, Christianity
and Judaism. Now, of course, there was
Arab paganism that was there as well.
But the fact that the major world
religions at the time was Christianity
and despite that fact, Islam
proliferated and spread in the way that
it did, it actually undoes the theory
that you have. And don't forget, Islam
spread far and wide from basically
southern France, Spain, Southern
Southern France all the way to China. So
the forms and different types of
religions they had, the different types
of philosophies they had, the different
kinds of societies they had was very
different in all these places. And Islam
found a home in all those places and
people from all kinds of cultures
adopted it. in by the way a much
different way than Christianity spread
because the way that Christianity spread
is that you had an established Roman
Empire and then you had an emperor
convert to Christianity in Constantine
and then you had other emperors that
enforced by force Christianity
throughout that empire. Whereas Islam
started
in the Arabian desert and through
conversion through war through this
through that through the other spread to
different countries. This is a different
situation because you did not have a
empire empire that converted to the
religion but you had an empire forming
because of the religion. It's a
completely different scenario.
So Christianity is one one of those
religions that actually spread due to
the fact that
you had a decision made by a couple of
decision makers where it's not really
the case like that with Islam. It was
more of organic spread and
proliferation. So the Ponzi scheme
expert comes in, butts in, and he says,
"Well, if you have a product this and
you have a product that and he's well,
you know, if this is not working, then
why are people in that?" Obviously
trying to use his Ponzi scheme uh, you
know, pyramid scheme knowledge to help
him understand a very complex or
different issue.
The the fact is this, people are
convinced with believing and worshiping
on one God. People are convinced with
the fact that the prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam is a true
prophet. Why? Because they look at his
life. They look at how he was, how kind
he was to disabled people like julib
to different segments of society. For
example, men, women, children.
For example, there's a there's a hadith
in Sah Bkari of a black woman coming to
the prophet Muhammad. black woman, the
type of woman that was marginalized and
humiliated in western society for many,
many years. She was saying that I
breastfed these two people and therefore
they cannot be together. The prophet
wasallam took her testimony seriously
and
divorced those two people because of
certain rules relating to breastfeeding
and so on and so forth. So he took the
testimony of this black woman seriously.
He respected and gave time and effort to
disabled people like Julib who had
dwarfism and who was marginalized by the
rest of the people in society. He spent
time with his wives and his wife said to
about him that he was never abusive.
Isha herself who you mention said that
he never hit any of his wives. He was
never abusive man. And at the same time
he would pray
twothirds of the night, one half of the
night and he would go out in military
expedition showing his bravery by being
on the front line in no less than 20
different military expeditions.
And don't tell me you don't respect
that. And what I want to ask
the Ponzi scheme expert and the tri
what I want to ask the pyramid scheme uh
expert is if you really had a problem
with men being with multiple women and
all these issues that this guy is
talking about, then why didn't you
mention that to Andrew Tate when you had
him multiple times on your podcast? Are
you scared of him? Scared to offend him?
Why didn't you bring this up and say,
"Well, actually, I think there should be
monogamy. One man, one woman, etc."
Because you want to be cool guy. You
want to be you want to fit in with the
youth. You don't want to contradictate.
You don't want to contradict people that
talk about having multiple women. But
when it comes to Islam, you'll use all
the liberal and feminist talking points.
You don't even know what you believe in,
frankly. And you don't even know why you
believe in it. And you haven't even made
a proper case and compelling case for
Christianity. Why should we believe
Christianity is true when they say that
the father is God, the son is God, and
the holy spirit is God, and that's not
three gods but one God.
That there are corrupted Bibles
everywhere. The New International
Version, the Revised Standard Version,
this that and the other. That your
countries in the West are becoming
Christian minority countries.
That people are leaving Christianity in
droves. that your book has not stood the
test of time.
If you look at the book of Genesis or
any other scientific description is so
far removed from the observable reality
of human beings today that people have
doubted it at such a level that there is
no return from it. This is not a
compelling case. This is the least
compelling case. The most compelling
case is to believe in one God, worship
in one God, and do what all the prophets
and messengers did beforehand, which is
the same thing what Abraham did, what
Moses did, and what Jesus did and what
Muhammad did, which is to worship one
God and to be good to your fellow man.
That's why people are becoming Muslim
and staying Muslim. Islam is growing.
Hey you, are you wasting your time on
social media? Again, your brothers and
sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a masid, a da center.
Establishing a masid to convey the
message of Islam is one of the best
deeds a Muslim can do. There's a huge
need for it in Norway. You know this and
I know this. So that makes the reward
even greater. So give generously and
Allahawel will give you even more.